A BAD DAY ON WALL STREET WITH A
HEAVY SELL-OFF IN THE TECH
SECTOR.
BRET?
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
GRIP OF INFORMATION HEADED
TOWARD THE U.S. BORDER IN THAT
BIG CONVOY.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT WILLIAM
LA JEUNESSE IS MONITORING
DEVELOPMENTS FROM LOS ANGELES.
>> A WEEK AGO, I CARE CARAVAN OF
CENTRAL AMERICANS WENT INTO
MEXICO BOUND FOR THE U.S.
>> Translator: AFTER HAVING
CROSSED TWO CHECKPOINTS, WE
HAVEN'T PERFORMED ANOTHER COUNT
BUT I ESTIMATE THERE ARE AROUND
1300.
>> ONLY SMOKE IMMIGRANTS, THEY
ARE GUIDED BY PEOPLE WITHOUT
BORDERS, A NONPROFIT ADVERTISING
THE TRIP AND RAISING MONEY
ONLINE, ALSO SAYING IT WILL
PROVIDE LEGAL ADVICE ON HOW
IMMIGRANTS CAN CLAIM ASYLUM UPON
REACHING THE U.S.
>> WE'LL TAKE THEM AND TO
CUSTODY, WE'LL DO OURS WITH HER
PROCESSING, AND TURN THEM OVER
TO I.C.E. AND I.C.E. WILL
RELEASE THEM BASED UPON WHAT
THEY CALL A CREDIBLE FEAR.
>> 80% OF THE CARAVAN IS FROM
HONDURAS.
MOST SAY THEY ARE FLEEING THE
VIOLENCE AND POVERTY.
THAT DOESN'T COUNT AS
PERSECUTION, STUDIES SHOW 88% TO
CLAIM ASYLUM ULTIMATELY GET
THEIR DATE IN IMMIGRATION COURT.
>> LET'S MAKE SURE IF THEY DO
COME TO THE U.S. BORDER, THEY
ARE ABLE TO GO THROUGH THE FULL
AND FAIR PROCESS OF SEEKING
ASYLUM AND THAT'S WHAT THEY